And everybody, this is Dr. Conner's again, and we're going to talk about some self-assessment
that can give you some answers, maybe some clues that you could give from a self-assessment
that might give you an idea of really what's going on in your body.
Let's just talk through these.
First clue is that, okay, your clinical red flag that you might have in a whole of your
diseases, nothing you've done is really helped.
So you've tried multiple things.
One of the key things that I see in intake forms over the years is people that have been to
10 other doctors or 15 other doctors, or call my staff and say, well, I bet everywhere
I've been to X amount of doctors, nothing ever seems to help.
Well, there's almost a 100% chance this person has an autoimmune disorder that has yet
to be diagnosed or is poorly managed.
Some people might know they have an autoimmune disease, but they're looking for a cure, or
they've been promised cures by different practitioners.
Of course, there aren't any cures for it, and they're just being poorly managed.
Maybe they have wrong expectations, too.
You got to take some of the blame, too.
You need to do your study, and that's what this course is for.
So it gives you proper expectations of being able to manage and deal with your disease,
and know that you have to come to some of this conclusion.
You can't just completely rely on some practitioner that's got the secret sauce for you.
Next thing I would say would be various treatments have helped at different times.
It's not uncommon that I talk to somebody, and they say that, well, I did this for this
period of time.
It seemed to really help, and now it doesn't seem to help anymore.
That's not uncommon with autoimmune disease.
Things can flare at for different reasons, and those reasons can change.
So something that may have worked for a period of time now doesn't seem to work anymore.
You have to find out what might be triggering this, something that you might be missing
in fire mentally, something you might be missing in your diet, and things can change
over time.
And I said that many times autoimmune diseases are progressive, maybe, that you have antibodies
to self-tissue.
You know, in one area of your body, it's not uncommon at all for a person with, let's
say, Hashimoto's, then to develop antibodies to their joint capsule cells, and now they
have collagen fiber antibodies that are developing rheumatoid at the same time.
So they're developing multiple autoimmune diseases.
Things can change you need to reassess.
Another common red flag is they have multiple reactions to different foods out here.
I just can't eat anything.
I seem to react to it, or I can't go in a room.
I could just sense that there's a mold in an office or in a room, and I can't go in there.
I had a patient once, I was practicing up in Duluth that couldn't come and see me in
the office because she said she reacted to everything, and I'm doubting her, but I had
to take a, put a desk in a, this was an old school that I was practicing in, had to put a desk
in the kitchen area where we ended up having to meet and have our initial consultation.
She was hyperreactive to everything that she had to remove everything from her house
and sleep in the center of the house of the floor on a sleeping bag.
Now these things are real and these things affect our body in different ways.
We have to start to identify these triggers and what's going on.
You know you have an autoimmune disease and you've got some sort of symptom pattern like
that.
Next is numerous diagnosis from doctors in the medical history.
I've touched on that already, been to 20 other doctors, been diagnosed with 20 different
things treated for them, didn't seem to help whatsoever, not getting to the root cause
of the disease, not getting to the root cause of what's going on, very common to see.
Next is a large supply of supplements in their house.
I had one person I asked her to bring in all her supplements, she run in 11 grocery
bags full of supplements.
She almost had more supplements than I had in my shelf to sell in my clinic at that time.
It was insane.
Now maybe she was just addicted to buying supplements, the truth was a lot of them weren't even
open.
She didn't even try them.
Everybody's looking for, you know, we're just like one supplement away from carrying our
problem.
Well that's not, that's just rarely the case.
So we need to dig into some testing to get some answers here.
The last thing is, a person may be diagnosed with multiple conditions, but they just do
not know that it's autoimmune, they might have hypothyroidism, but nobody ever tested them
for TPO or other thyroid antibodies, they might have diabetes, nobody ever tested them for
anti-bodies to insulin, anti-bodies to pancreatic cells, flammatory bowel disease.
They just have gut issues, but nobody ever tested them for anti-bodies.
So they know, they know they have a condition, but they don't know that it's really, that
their condition is really tied to having antibodies to self tissue, and that is what flares it.
So they're not catching on to what's really flaring their disease, immune stimulation
is flaring their disease.
The other thing that I add to this is that people are taking immune stimulants and that flares
the disease.
That's another sign that you have an autoimmune disease.
Every time I take vitamin C, I seem to get worse, or I take some echinacea, I seem to
get worse.
So what am I supposed to do?
This was the treatment that my doctor said I had Lyme disease, so I'm starting to take
cat's claw and I seem to get worse and he just said that it's a herximer reaction.
Well, the truth is, yeah, you could be having a herximer reaction, but it's more common
that you have actually autoimmune phase.
You're in autoimmune disease, and by stimulating your immune system, you're going to kill that
which you have antibodies against.
First of all, you're going to make yourself worse.
So a key component to unlocking some secrets, do I have an autoimmune disease, do immune stimulants
make me worse?
Well, throughout this course, we're going to be digging into all of this.
So we got a lot to go through, a lot to study.
That's what this is all about.
So hey, you there.
We're going to uncover all of these things and hopefully comb everything down.